Bị dừng xe k yểm chân ở đất con,
ruyến văn thắng bà bị tư tuổi.
Đặc ngá xe rồi, chăm lợ đốt,
truyến bối và đe dọa củ,
cạnh xác dấu thương.
Chưa hai môi tháng 2,
cạnh xác dấu thông phát hiện thắng lại sẽ mấy
tại khu vực phương, càm lình, hạnh phố càm dành,
không đổi mũ bọc hiệm, không gương chíu hậu,
chở theo một phủ nước,
nên đại yêu cầu dừng xe k yểm chắc dây tờ nó nổng độ con.
Buy nhiên, lưới này không chắc ai,
liên tục xâm tới đe dọa,
chửi bối lực lượng chức năng,
sau đó thắng đặc ngá xe,
bởi nó bị sàng và chăm lợ.
Chị vai xe, xem hoặc chái,
thắng tục đứng cạnh xác để gây hình.
Cạnh xác dấu thông phối hợp cung ăn phường,
càm lình giập lợ,
truy sát và bắt dữ thắng.
Ngày 25, 2 công ty khánh hoàn đạm dữ thắng
tể điều tra về hành vi trong người thiện có vụ.
Lực lượng chức năng xanh lịt lúc thực hiện thành vi,
thắng dương tính với chết mặt thuy,
đừng có tiền ăn tảng chữ chai phép chết mặt thuy.